yeah so uh and uh I'm it's a pleasure to
share this particular station
so uh Tom marking is gonna tell us about
minimal complexity assumption for
cryptography
okay hi everyone so this question I've
been asked many times in the past few
days when are you going to talk about
um
and I still don't fully know but
um
let me uh quote what I was asked by the
organizers to do they wanted me to cover
survey the basic concepts and Main open
questions and cryptography as well as
what is known with black box reductions
Etc
okay and the key point is to make it
accessible to all Serious Program
participants and therefore borrowing to
The Experts that's what I was asked to
do now I want to say it's clearly
impossible to cover everything
um in general it's impossible and also
given the answer that I gave to this
email which is I will have extremely
little time to prepare the talk do you
still want me to talk and they said yes
so nonetheless I'm gonna try to address
some non-empty subset of these things uh
and I would like you to help me help me
make it accessible and boring and ask a
lot of questions okay and discussions
and answer the questions Etc
um so
uh what am I going to talk about so
first of all I also wanted to add so
this is like a survey I don't know of
everything
um oh everything from if you were here
in Rafael's talk everything like from
here and to the right if you remember
from Rafael stock
um definitely not attempting to be
complete and it's very biased sample uh
it will not be heavy on proofs there
will be hand waving I'll give a bunch of
definitions but not super formally
uh and there'll be a lot of color lots
of colors or Phil said he doesn't like
many colors I don't usually either but
this one has a ton of colors it's very
retro a bunch of the slides are from my
job talk and other talks in the 2000s
and even then there was a retro 80s
disco Vibe you will see
so that's uh I don't necessarily
recommend you do talks like that but
this is what it is uh what else I'm
gonna start with stuff that's really old
and um experts definitely know it
um and then later I'll talk about some
often problems that I would be happy to
work on my goal is to give like some
overview and some ideas of things that
are interesting open problems that are
interesting if you want to talk to me
about them or to each other
okay that's what I'm going to talk about
I know it was very unclear hopefully it
will become clearer okay so cryptography
in the last 2000 years
uh see Rafael's intro so this is for
real I know this is recorded if
somebody's just watching this recording
you really should go back and see like
the the very beginning of Raphael's talk
is exactly an introduction I was going
to give to cryptography in the last 2000
years so uh happily I don't need to do
it
um and what I will really talk about is
about assumptions and cryptography so
here is the narrative that um often is
being told and indeed it's true and
we've seen it several times in Raphael
stock and then all the other talks and
several other talks uh all the talks I
think so far touched upon these things
uh for most cryptographic tasks we
cannot hope to give unconditional proofs
of security as they would imply you know
the collapse of the hierarchy they would
imply that NP is hard
um on average which we don't know how to
do
um so first of all this people always
say it's not quite true there's
definitely a lot of rich and beautiful
information theoretic cryptography which
was also mentioned here I think in Rahul
stock
um right there's lots of stuff that you
can do information theoretically with no
assumptions and there's some examples
here uh that came up in a bunch of them
like secret sharing and one-time
encryption they already came up in a
previous talk these the information
theoretic things they tend to be
so why why I think both narratives are
correct that everything in cryptography
requires one way function and yet
there's a lot of cryptography
information theoretically
I think the information theoretic things
tend to be either multiple parties and
then you know maybe some of them are
honest or something like that or things
that are for limited number of
executions or like there's non-malleable
code example here you don't need to
understand all of these things I just
I'm giving an overview I think there the
point is the adversary is weaker than
the good guy so there are some settings
in which information theoretic suffices
however this will not be our Focus today
and so I'm going to continue with the
narrative that we must make some
assumptions so let's talk about which
assumptions we can make and how to
minimize them
okay please do interrupt me I would love
it
that assumption that is a hard yeah but
I agree with that uh but that's almost
by definition right if it's not
information theoretic then it needs an
assumption
will be a minimal assumption ah exactly
okay I agree with this point so let me
repeat it anything in cryptography
that's not information theoretic as far
as we know maybe I in fact you could
find some weird counter examples
it does not require anything but I will
talk about it anyway the the spirit of
what ammo says is definitely true
one-way function is necessary
okay so but anyway I actually didn't say
anything here about uh one-way function
I'm just making the point that we have
to study assumptions and see what they
are
um so there are very ideally we would
like to prove it based on I don't know
NP it's hard on average but there are
barriers that Raphael mentioned other
talks mentioned I think we didn't see
any talk that really goes into those
barriers that would be interesting in
the future maybe in the crypto Workshop
that will be at the end I don't know it
just sounds to me very interesting to
discuss more
the barriers
but instead people may concrete
assumptions like from number Theory
there's a bunch a list of assumptions
here
um you know factoring is very famous but
they're also like AES there's also an
assumption
um we heard about a lot about filmograph
there's a bunch of assumptions that
people make
um
good in this talk so why do we trust
these assumptions because many people
worked on it they tried hard Etc I think
you know this narrative
um on one hand there's some tension on
one hand we want more assumptions it's
better to have more assumptions and
cryptography more sources of hardness
because what if what we already have
turns out to be false like I don't know
factoring is broken by a quantum
computer
what if other things will all be broken
so it's good to have a lot of sources of
hardness on the other hand we want to
unify the universe we want to have as
minimal assumptions as possible we want
to have assumptions few assumptions that
people can really work very hard and
therefore we gain confidence in them so
the way we negotiate this and my focus
on the stock will be
um to focus on cryptographic Primitives
so I will not really talk about lattices
or any of these things written here but
in fact I will talk about cryptographic
Primitives and then these Primitives can
be instantiated different Primitives
with different assumptions or sometimes
with the same assumptions and then if
the assumptions is false we could still
try to instantiate the same primitive
with a different assumption okay so this
is uh the point of view in this talk I
will focus on cryptographic Primitives
yeah so this is what we want to do I'll
show I'll say which cryptographic
Primitives like one refunction that came
up but also other ones
um
good I don't think I need to convince
you that it's interesting to study
reductions and understand implications
um so this brings us to impelliatsu's uh
world
um which were mentioned in every single
talk many times and rightfully so that's
that sort of tries to bring together
and this idea these are this is a
picture from Marshall's
uh
Marshall from his job talk I guess and
he said was it from your job talk I
don't know from what uh that he allowed
me to use what it was in my job it was
in your job though okay anyway these are
the uh five worlds Rafael and others
talked extensively about uh all the way
through minicrypt uh one way functions
this I'll talk more about them uh and
then there's crypto Mania where publicly
cryptography exists
um Raphael added another world on the
left I'll add another word on the right
World on the right but it's not mine uh
it's another world that uh people have
suggested after uh in the last 10
years uh which is a world where you can
be your best self and have the best life
you can have everything is possible our
world is called opustopia
I try to this is me trying to finagle
Marshall's drawing but I'm not as good
I'm trying to imitate his handwriting uh
anyway this is a fistopia where we have
in addition to publicly cryptography
also uh indistinguishability of
frustration so I will try to talk about
what we know about assumptions in these
worlds and what can be done Etc
um good any questions so far
yes first of all yeah this so I love
this question I can convey the question
to somebody else in the audience who
will answer Marshall what is the meaning
of the picture for Pepsi language
all right uh good yeah it's it's better
because everything right easy is good
and hard is good for cryptography or for
algorithms in testing land it's like
easy but not easy enough and hard but
not hard enough it's terrible
um okay why do you say PK plus
indistinguishable obfuscation I suppose
if you just say distinguish into the
obfuscation that does exist If people
could be exactly that's exactly the
reason B plus indistinguishability okay
this is a good why don't so good first
of all I want to say this is a great
question so so the question was why do I
Define so I'll maybe let me okay I'll
answer now and I'll answer again when I
get to it why do I Define austopia
speaker e plus and distinguishability
obfuscation one could just say
indistinguishably you know like in
crypto menu I didn't write public key
plus one refund [ __ ] I just wrote public
key why because public key implies
one-way function so it's enough to write
it here in office not enough to write in
distinguishable the obfuscation I'll
talk about it because it's in fact does
not imply the previous one so we know
the simplest answer is I just wanted it
to be obviously clear that they are
growing in complexity without any
problems I'm trying to present a picture
that's like simple Amos Amos Amos you
ask later when I talk about it uh I will
leave time for discussions among the
audience
um so I wanted to start but this is also
something about the overview of my talk
I wanted to start by presenting a very
clean clean clean picture and then
immediately after I'll say the picture
is highly unclean there are many
complications going on that's my next
message
this page I still wanted the picture to
be clean so this is clearly more than
the previous one it's everything in the
previous plus one more
um we could say indistinguishability
Obsession plus NP is hard on average and
that in fact
if you ignore some infinitely often I
don't know what is in fact the same but
I will say more about it
good
Now by this point in the
in in the boot camp you should know what
one-way functions are but if you don't
know any of the other words it's fine uh
here's more words
um Okay so
these are a bunch of known
um
reductions
implications so there is a if and only
for an implication if there is a
reduction I guess a touring reduction
but I'm not very precise I will not be
very precise but uh this is the classic
perspective on how people describe these
things it's also correct when I say
classic perspective today the
perspective has shifted a bit but still
I'm not lying in anything I'm saying
um so in minicrypt the idea is there's a
ton of Primitives they're all there was
a big body of work and it was all very
pleasing and beautiful it's all
equivalent to each other when we
functions if and only if pseudo random
generators to the random functions
digital signature schemes private key
encryption and more and more and more
things it's all very neat and tight and
equivalent to each other and that's
minicrypt uh so the red ones are the
ones that in polyatsu chose to highlight
in his definition of these worlds he
defined many Crypts as one-way function
but no key agreement
in crypto Mania with key agreement and
no one-way function I'll Define a lot of
these Primitives like immediately soon
um in this talk
um okay so and these are different
Primitives that imply each other so we
know I don't know trapdoor functions in
pi public encryption Etc there's all
kinds of affirmative is going on I'll
show you this picture again after I
Define some of the Primitives
okay so this is still kind of clean
picture my message would be that the
picture is really a lot more messy and
there are many interesting things that
happen
um good
so when we function you already know let
me uh just write the definition this is
we've already seen the definition I will
just f is a one-way function if it's
efficiently computable but hard to
invert
um the font seems a little weird but
okay but hard to invert so
um I'll just highlight that it's an
average case obviously definition so you
choose an input at random you compute f
of x you give it to the adversary the
adversary should not be able to invert
it
second negligible probability and there
are variations like Raphael discussed
week one functions Etc
um okay and from one-way functions we
can construct private key encryption
which I will not Define formally but
I'll just say you know it's the standard
notion of encryption Alice and Bob agree
in advance on the secret key and then
they can send messages to each other
I'll Define public encryption in a
minute
um
okay so this is uh when we function in
this but this picture that I showed
before this is sort of the reason why
everybody says you mean one-way function
as the bottom thing and everything
implies it
um
good there's also trapdoor functions
which are very similar to this this is
this is a Highline formal definition
um but
I think it's good enough uh it's a you
can sample from uh the function and then
it's easy to compute uh given the you
can sample a function it's easy to
compute On Any X but it's hard to invert
it's a one-way function but given a
trapdoor it's easy to invert okay oh by
the way I didn't mention because my talk
is not focusing on
um specific assumptions but just if like
to give an example
I don't know from one-way function an
example is you know G to the X mod P
like for discrete log or
uh
[Music]
these are examples for candidates that
we believe are one-way function okay but
anyway I will not focus on the concrete
assumptions okay so uh that's it that's
a chapter function you can also consider
trapdoor permutations
which are uh where f is from
D to D from the same domain to itself
okay there's it's important that they're
enhanced
but I didn't want to Define what it
means exactly uh
unless if you want me to I can it won't
be important for my talk
but it's important for the what I wrote
on the slide to be actually correct
basically enhanced travel permutation is
that you can sample from the image
without actually knowing the pre-image
three images or because otherwise it's
equivalent to only functions huh it's
probably to one
is that what you're asking so yeah it
has to be public one if it's not quality
one I don't know if that actually
addresses what you're asking but it has
to be fully to when there's no
restriction
why is it equivalent to another function
it's not
well I don't know
The Constructor functions
if Justified that where there is this
like it's it's almost problem yeah
right yeah
like that's a publicly be a favor and
then you always lets the r be a pretty
much to like you can always
invert the public Keys
one is what solves this right I want to
find some examples you're saying that
something here is wrong
the chapter functions don't imply like
public encryption is that what you're
saying well like maybe if you had that
ball to one thing yeah probably to work
yeah I am adding to one sorry
I thought you were arguing that even
that is not enough yeah it has to be
poet once yes if you only have
exponential to to one if you just have
that today you can get it from one way
function yeah because you just say that
you can always
you can have an extra pre-emerge which
is just uh if you can invert the public
key that allows you to
that gives you like a dummy
chapter pretty much
you're saying from one-way functions you
can get trapdoor functions that have
exponentially many prematures yeah yeah
right the definition should be pulling
too much pull it to one you say like if
I know uh R then output to the second
part or something like that yeah yeah
right
good
it should be probably two one but still
it's less structure than travel
fermentation say right or regular
strepto function
yes what's the definition
oh the the the size of the pre-image I
guess that the size of the pyramid
should be polynomial
it you know so you know what one to one
is pulling to one polynomial and the
length of Exon input of length n Bits
there's uh only polynomially many inputs
that map to the same output I see and
that's worst case right for all
it's worst case but in all of these
definitions if you have a tiny tiny tiny
fraction
so I I think it's fine even if it's not
worst case uh but let's define it to be
worst case
um I mean the typical uh
example for example is I don't know
squaring more than what
and which of course B times Q something
like that so if you know the
characterization you can invert
before
Okay so so
uh public key encryption and key
agreement sorry this now it's almost
done there won't be many there's a bunch
of slides that just tell you something
about the Primitive so we can talk about
the more and in a more informed way
um good so publicly encryption I drew it
as a communication just because later
I'll talk about or not later in the next
line will be about key agreement which
will extend it to many rounds public
encryption you can think of an algorithm
a protocol with two rounds between Alice
and Bob where Alice sends a public key
and Bob sends an encryption of a message
importantly it's randomized so it's a
triple of algorithms GED G is a key
generation algorithm
that takes Randomness and gives you a
public key and a secret key e encrypts e
gets the encryption gets public key
message and Randomness and gives you a
cipher text and the decryption algorithm
can recover the message from the
ciphertext this is the correctness
definition
um and the security definition is that
any adversary any passive adversary that
sees everything on the line so given p k
and C
does not learn any information about the
message that was encrypted okay and this
turns out to be equivalent to saying uh
that the distribution of an encryption
of one message of any for any two
messages distribution of encryption of
one of them and the other one of them
are indistinguishable
okay
and finally key agreement is exactly the
same thing but in many rounds so there's
Alice and Bob and they discuss for many
rounds and then they agree on some maybe
it's not obvious that it's the same but
it is that key agreement in two rounds
is public encryption they discussed for
several rounds at the end they have to
Output some key
uh this is the correctness and the
security is that no adversary that sees
the entire transcript uh can distinguish
the key from random
any questions
okay I wanted to make a note about
trapdoor function versus uh public key
encryption they seem very similar and I
just wanted to put it out there that you
can
think in some intuitive way it's a moral
way of a chapter function as a stronger
de-randomized version of public key
encryption
okay why do I say that in chapter
function the task
uh is from the output so that the in in
chapter function the key generation
algorithm gives you I didn't specify it
formally before it gives you uh index to
the function K and some trapdoor and
then you can compute f of x but it's
hard to recover X without the trapdoor
and it's easy to recover x with the
trapdoor in public key encryption the
encryption algorithm takes M and
Randomness R and gives you some
ciphertext C and then going from the
ciphertext C back to the message is easy
if you have the secret key but notice
that we don't have R we cannot recover R
necessarily so you can view them as very
similar definitions except this one is
randomized uh there's a Randomness that
you might not be the decryption
algorithm may not be able to recover
okay and indeed trapdoor functions imply
public encryption
um
any questions
okay I think that was the oh yeah
there's oblivious transference secure
computation that's the last one for now
um
good so this is oblivious transfer
primitive
sorry let me stop for a minute anybody
has any questions
okay so uh OT oblivious transferred
defined by Robin or I guess some similar
version was defined by Robin
um is Alice has so again this is not a
formal definition you can Define it with
Ideal World Etc this is not a formal
definition but the idea is the following
Alice has two Secrets as zero S1 Bob has
a bit B they get involved in some uh
correspondence and at the end of the day
Alice gets absolutely no information
about anything new
and Bob uh learns SB so Bob can uh this
is oblivious transfer Bob can choose
either s0 or S1 whatever he wants and
learns nothing at all about the other
one okay so for example if these are
bits he can he doesn't uh he can only
guess them with probability half
that's negligible
okay that's called one out of two OT
uh and uh
so and you can think of it as secure
computation of this specific function
you know F of s0 s1b equals bottom and
SB
um so this is a super powerful
Primitives because A Primitive because
it allows General secure computation if
you assume you have a secure
implementation of OT you can get secure
computation
any function
good any questions
so that's for Passive otherwise yeah
that's well so you can Define this
definition doesn't have anything formal
you can Define OT against an active
adversary and against a passive
adversary but let's keep it passive
um somehow you know I drew this picture
and before which I'll show again
there are many many there are many kinds
of secure computation many kinds of OT
um adaptive non-adaptive let's assume
the simplest version that everybody's uh
passive yeah
did you define secured computations
um no here I am here is secure
computation
computation is so
um
computation of a specific function in
general secure computation uh again
let's think about in the passive case
like you asked
uh they're in parties two or more
parties each party has an input XI party
I has input XI and they want to compute
some function of their inputs okay or F
of X1 to XM and each party needs to get
some output okay that basically captures
almost anything you can think about
okay and the idea is what do we want to
do we want to be able to achieve it
securely what is the definition of
security
um it's fairly easy to Define if you
only think about a passive adversary
um but basically you want the um any
adversary that sees everything yeah what
do you mean by effective adversity
yeah and I'm just so so given an
adversary that sees all the
communication that happens
um good again you can Define uh the
adversary can correct some number of
parties and then he can see everything
that they have yeah but they follow the
protocol they followed the protocol
that's what passive is yeah this is just
because to make it a little more
concrete you can Define it for active
adversary that doesn't follow the
protocol basically the upshot is this
you can achieve secure computation for
any function
there are upper bounds and lower bounds
for active adversary and passive
adversary how many parties uh they are
allowed to corrupt Etc you can achieve
this even information theoretically but
then you have to assume honest majority
and more assumptions uh with OT you can
do it even for two parties uh like Alice
and Bob
um yeah and the chief secure computation
so
[Music]
this this was the definition of some of
the
um
of some of the Primitives here what I
wanted to talk about so it's known the
all these implications are known and
this is very old stuff meaning
um I guess there's a bunch of new things
that happen and the E is like not that
old adding the noticing that you need
enhanced there are many many things
going on there that I'm not going to
talk about
um
but somehow this is the classic
perspective this is the picture
um
good so it seems intuitively clear and
obvious that I don't know public
encryption is harder than private key
encryption
right so and in general all the things
in crypto Mania seem to be harder than
all the things in minicrypt in some
intuitive way it seems clear but both in
terms of efficiency often of
constructions we have but also in in
terms of assumptions we have and also
just in terms of a gut feeling right
public key encryption you need to be
able to
um you know send some secret message to
somebody in over a public Channel
without ever meeting in a secret alley
it seems inherently harder but what does
it so we want to prove something like
that we want to prove that it's actually
harder okay but how would we separate
these things right
um what does it even mean this logically
it doesn't quite make sense to say that
it's harder first of all they all might
not exist so they all might be fall
false like I don't know maybe we live in
algorithmica but even in even if we live
in crypto Mania and they all exist then
in which way is this easier than that
they all exist right so in some logical
way it's not clear what it means
[Music]
um
right how can you say a doesn't imply B
right you could always if both A and B
exist you can always construct B here's
a reduction don't use a and just
construct B and it exists and therefore
it's great okay so uh in paliato and
rudish in 99 suggested
um
the approach of proving separation via
Black Box reduction okay so I wanted to
say a little bit about that
um okay so they eliminate Black Box
reductions I'll say a little more about
that yes
the previous slide or next slide
then you hope to get like equivalence at
the top yeah so I think at that
point I don't know and uh
when was it 89 in Korea I would guess
that in 89 the Hulk was to get
equivalence or you know he did Russell
defined five worlds I think somehow
maybe I don't know what I don't want to
speak for him but the home for us to
have a lot of like five worlds and in
each world everything is tied and all
equivalent to each other it would be
nice if they're all equivalent to each
other I think that was the and for some
specific implications here it was more
of um
people for example Trader function and
public key encryption people did
basically treat them as the same
somehow intuitively I'm not saying and
nobody claimed this in a paper but
people treated them as basically the
same thing and you know most public
encryptions we know are based on
although not all are based on
assumptions that come from trapdoor
functions
a metal like some El Gamal you don't
have a trapdoor there
um so I I would say it would be nice if
they're all equivalent but as a spoiler
there will not be uh yeah that's that's
part of the like how it's not so uh
beautiful
like which which is also interesting
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on
good so let me say something about Black
Box reductions
um
okay so
um also again each of these things
slides is like I could give a whole
lecture in a class on so I apologize for
not giving many details but hopefully
forgive something
um so a black box construction or
primitive B from a intuitively is like
you construct the Primitive B from a
using only its input output
um
input output Behavior but even more
importantly the proof of security is
also Black Box
um so there are many versions of black
box and there's a paper by
um rangol travisan and vadan who
discusses all of them I would recommend
to read it if you're interested in Black
Box reductions for me black box is what
they call fully black box that's what
I'm defining here so importantly the
proof of security also needs to be Black
Box what is the proof of security recall
when I construct a primitive B I don't
know maybe I'm constructing a public
here trying to construct public
encryption from private key encryption
say I don't know so B uses a in a black
box way but then how do I prove it's
secure I prove that oh if you had
an adversary for B then I can use it to
construct an adversary for a
contradiction so we want that part to
also be Black Box okay that's what Black
Box reduction is
fully Black Box reduction is
good and most reductions that we know I
can say something about exceptions in a
minute but most reductions that we know
are a black box are in cryptography
um so
given such a black box reduction it
turns out to be relativizing that turns
out it like follows directly that it's
relativizing what is a relativizing
reduction it means that if you prove
that a implies B using a black box
reduction like this
so if aim plays B
um then A would imply B relative to any
other Oracle as well if your proof is a
black box like this
right
um
good
everybody
has access to the Oracle yeah so uh yeah
the so here you see yeah I you see the
adversary has access both to the
original a and to the adversary for B
and the adversary for B has Oracle
access to a yeah so our reduction is
black box if this
happens and this implies in particular
that it's also relativizing that it's
true with respect to every
um
Oracle
it's good so
following this this is
Oracle suppression Paradigm is the
following in order to show for example
that private key encryption is easier
than public encryption or any two
Primitives their idea is this you
construct some Oracle gamma then you
prove so then you prove that relative to
gamma primitive a exists so that
eliminates the whole issue of well we
don't know if this exists in the first
place or maybe they both exist Etc so
the idea is construct an oracle gamma
such that relative to gamma a exists but
B does not exist
okay this immediately proves that
there's no relativizing reduction uh of
b2a and therefore also no black box
reduction of b2a and therefore
um I'll say more about therefore in a
minute okay that was their suggestion
and using the suggestion they proved
that there's no black box uh reduction
of key agreement to one-way function and
I wanted to give you a
very little small idea of the proof of
this okay just to give you an idea how
it works
um
good let me see so I'm reminding you
what are we proving we're proving that
one-way function does not imply key
agreement in a black box way okay and
we're going to follow this idea so
the Oracle so the Oracle they choose has
two parts one part A is a completely
random function chosen completely at
random and one part B is a p space
complete Oracle or any Oracle with
respect to which p is equal to NP
okay why we'll see in a minute
so as a first step they prove that the
Oracle a is a one-way function
okay what does it mean that it's a
one-way function so a truly random
function that you have you cannot invert
in polynomial time and in fact you can
even prove that you cannot inverted even
an exponential time as long as you only
access the oracle
polynomially many times you cannot
invert it except with negligible
probability okay that's not too hard to
prove
it's even given the b art code right
good exactly so first let's start yes
exactly but let's start with just a so a
is this is not so hard to prove
um but now we added another Oracle B
I'll say I'll get back to it in one
second
um
additionally this is the hard part the
previous was not so hard this one is
hard you want to prove that there exists
no security agreement protocol relative
uh to this uh Oracle so let me see maybe
if we write something
you maybe use the bar that might be
easier so what do they do there's oh
Alice and Bob there's Alice
Bob and let's assume there was some key
agreement supposed key agreement
protocol both of them have access
initially to a I will add b in a minute
okay a is a truly random function so we
know it's a one-way function they both
have access to this and now we want to
prove the next step wants to prove that
there exists no such protocol that is
secure against Eve as follows against an
adversary that
uh gets this whole transcript so the
adversary Eve gets this whole transcript
and tries to figure out the key at the
end of the day Alice and Bob agree on a
key as an output of this interaction
um so initially at this point
good
um let me assume that Eve is exponential
unbounded adversary okay I'll make Eve
bounded in a minute if it's exponential
unbounded adversary can work as much as
she wants
exponential time however Eve is only
allowed polynomially many queries to a
okay in this regime they first proof of
the first step maybe they didn't phrase
it like this this phrasing is more along
the lines of Barack and mahmudi but this
is basically what they did just phrased
in a more modern
uh words
here is what Eve will do there's a way
for Eve to look at this transcript and
figure out what the key is how will she
do that here is a rough idea
first let's assume if Alice and Bob for
in this protocol never used the oracle
um
then
definitely there's no security agreement
because if it's exponential is unbounded
there is no unconditionally secure key
agreement so they must have used this
Oracle that's the only Bound for Eve the
T agreement oh I didn't say it
explicitly but when I said all of these
things in crypto require assumptions
it's not hard to prove
so that key agreement cannot be done
information theoretically
um good so they must have queried this a
okay moreover if Bob and Alice queried
this a and some they can query on
whatever they want if they queried on
all queries that are not the same in
Alice and Bob
they don't really matter I mean all of
this needs to be proven so if they
manage to agree on a key
um
somehow
well either Eve can figure it out but if
if cannot figure it out initially it
means that it came from the Oracle a so
what they do is they show how to what if
does is she keeps sampling
um
transcripts that are consistent with
what you saw so far and if this
transcript require Alice or Bob to query
the Oracle Eve queries the Oracle and
corrects the transcript something along
these lines I'm obviously not giving a
full proof okay but at the end of the
day she can sample enough transcripts so
that she even also query the Oracle in
all important queries that are joined
for Alice and Bob and therefore she can
figure out okay
I don't know if this is convincing but
this is the general idea it's very nice
um okay once you do it like this so now
I know there is no key agreement
protocol secure against exponential Eve
that has only polynomially many queries
to the oracle
now they show that if they add B here
which is a piece based complete Oracle
that's the next step you add B here so
everybody has access to it it's a pspace
complete article with respect to which p
is equal to NP now they show first of
all what we've not said before that a is
still a one-way function a random
function is still a one-way function
even if p is equal to NP okay that's
again not too hard to prove so first
they need to prove that it's still a
one-way function so even with respect to
both of them even though Alice and Bob
can now solve sat
that they still cannot invert a
and then that's one and then moreover
Eve can now be implemented efficiently
because she has access to she can solve
sat and that helps Implement Eve
efficiently this is the high level idea
of the Oracle separation okay so from
this we concluded that there exists an
oracle this is the Oracle with respect
to which uh
one-way functions exist but key
agreement does not exist therefore there
is no relativizing and therefore no
black box reduction does this make sense
yes exactly and and yeah B is to make
sure it can be done polynomial time
because the definition of key agreement
is polynomial time but it's interesting
even without this
um yes
good
um
yes
I said all of this so after that there
are many other Oracle separations
um
and let me maybe say like two words so
there are many many many article
separations between many different
Primitives
um
many of them followed this
Paradigm of adding a Oracle relative to
which one thing exists and the other one
doesn't let me mention uh there's some
other paradigms that can happen
um
let me think whether to mention it or
not
I guess let me mention it
um
I'll mention two other paradigms of
Oracle separations
um or maybe let me one second
uh yeah okay let me say here's another
uh Paradigm which does not so this this
idea proves that there's no relativizing
reduction and therefore no black box
reduction you could also flip the order
of quantifiers uh here's another
paradigm
um
this was used in gmr it's a paper of
mine with the L gerther and Omar Rango
where it was important to do this
which I'll explain in a minute why but
anyway another Paradigm is this uh
for any this is I'm just flipping the
order of quantifier quantifiers for any
suggested
reduction or construct for any suggested
Black Box
uh reduction where somebody claims that
some primitive P implies Q
uh
construct an oracle
gamma such that he exists
relative to gamma
but the suggestion the suggested
Construction
of Q does not
okay so it changes the order of
quantifiers I'm not giving you one
Oracle with respect to which P exists
but no Q exists no maybe with respect to
my Oracle gamma there's so for example
if I wanted to do this for private key
encryption versus public encryption
which why would I want to the
intellectual this thing is better but
just as an example I would say well I
you give me you let me tell you the
example we actually did it for we showed
we use this to show and I'll tell you
why it was important we use this to show
that in fact public key encryption does
not imply
uh trapdoor function in a black box way
this is what we wanted to show
um and there it was very hard to use the
previous Paradigm because
basically what I told you before first
of all this is a little surprising
because people thought of these are
basic as basically the same but as I
told you before this is sort of a the
randomized version and somehow if I give
you an oracle with a random function
it's it's hard to prove this separation
um so what we did instead is we said
well give me any you you claim that
there is a construction of a traveler
function from public encryption great
give me your construction I'm going to
show you an oracle where your
construction failed
okay so for every construction there's
an oracle where it fails okay that's one
different paradigm
and this and this one one more second
and this Paradigm does not uh rule out
relativizing reductions it does not
there might still be a relativizing
reduction but it does rule out black box
reductions yes
so you have so I guess to give a precise
definition I would have to say what the
Primitive is like a one-way function or
or public key encryption Etc but so
let's let's say public encryption is a
triple of algorithm GED right so
um I want to say that there exists an
algorithm G gamma e gamma D gamma so
everybody has access to gamma both the
good
uh algorithms and the adversary so in
order to say that there exists a public
encryption with respect to my gamma I
will show an algorithm GED
that act that can access gamma it will
that implement the key generation
encryption and decryption oracles and
I'll prove to you that it's uh the
correctness holds and I'll prove to you
uh security Now what is the definition
of security the definition of security
is that for any you can say any
polynomial time a or often it's enough
to think about exponential time with
polynomial access to the Oracle but
let's say for every polynomial time a
a has access to gamma
um
uh a a
for every a for every polynomial time a
gamma a doesn't
uh learn anything about it's the
standard definition I cannot distinguish
an encryption of Zero from an encryption
of one
not to distinguish
version of Zero from encryption of one
encryption with the public key
with the gamma so I I think you're
asking what is it what is gamma where
gamma comes from everybody has access to
gamma the Primitive existing is just the
standard definition of whatever the
Primitive is like public key encryption
and for the trapdoor function for
example to prove that it doesn't exist
I'll show you a specific adversary that
breaks your thing
and in terms of constructions it's
yeah it usually works as you give an
oracle that implements this that's
usually easy but then you add another
Oracle that tries to
foil this and then you have to prove
that it didn't fall the other one these
proofs are notoriously annoying
uh they're long and complicated and
yeah I was just wondering if you just
enough it depends on the
the framework some in the logic
sometimes it is used slightly
differently is it enough to assume that
the government exists
it's not that I assume that it exists I
prove that it exists
and I I construct gamma
for instance relative to gamma something
exists so is it enough to assume the
predominances
okay I see I see gamma it's not like I
assume something about Gamma Gamma is
something for example gamma would
consist of a random length tripling
function okay I tell you what will be in
gamma the gamma might have a random
length tripling function and might have
another function that inverts it
okay
okay good this is one kind of different
Oracle separation and there's a
completely other there actually many
other kinds of Oracle suppression
there's another Oracle separation that
doesn't rule out things but rather
counts uh rules out it gives a lower
bound on efficiency something like oh in
order to create this primitive from that
primitive you have to use it at least
this many times
okay if it's a black box construction or
else I don't know I would manage to do
the same construction unconditionally
which is a contradiction something like
that that's another Oracle separation
and there are newer Oracle separations
yeah so really the only difference from
uh is that here the Oracle depends on
the construction
that's the only difference it also means
the result is weaker it doesn't rule out
relativizing reductions but it still
rules out
Black Box reductions okay
good are there any unroad passing
constructions known
um I think this leads beautifully to my
next slide if I don't answer within the
two slides ask again uh good what the
Black Box operations mean I don't know
if this slide might have come from Omar
Rango or maybe not I don't remember
after so many years uh okay so this this
is the answer to your question almost
all reductions in cryptography are uh
black box and in particular also
relativizing
um the basic so there's one exception
although it appears in several places
the one big exception is zero knowledge
for NP now I didn't even Define zero
knowledge but the point is every
language in NP has a zero knowledge
proof How does it go how do we prove
that we prove it from one specific
language like I don't know three color
abilities and then to prove zero
knowledge for another language you need
to do like a reduction a cook 11
reduction and that is highly non-black
box right because you look at the
Cleveland deterministic turing machine
computation Etc so everywhere I need to
say oh there is a zero knowledge proof
for this language well first I'm going
to reduce this language to three color
ability and then I'll use my zero
knowledge proof for the threefold
building that step
is not Black Box because I need to see
the machine so this comes up in some
applications like I don't know
applications involving zero knowledge
like some you know taking secure
computation from honest to malicious or
some identification scheme so there's
some examples but they're very very few
like all the examples I showed before on
the big slide were the many things they
were all black box so their knowledge
would give you like no black box
constructions right
the reductions if you're saying the
proof would still be the adversary
um you know as a as a blackball if your
theorem is also that one-way function
Supply that all empty languages have
zero knowledge proofs you even the
construction also uses the one-way
function in a black box way as long as
you're not trying
okay so you you're agreeing with we know
then that it's but it's okay so these
are two different points actually okay
there's reduction versus proof and you
are saying in the interim using the one
with but but this this might be
important
now we know better but at that point I
think constant runs your knowledge from
what we function required non-blackbooks
use everybody
or that's oryx is true okay so at this
point you're saying nothing is really
deeply non-blacked today actually we
have like postal structures from what
infection also but at that point all
concentrate constructions actually were
known by focusing money function
let me say it in this way
um if I want to use the fact I don't
know where how I proved it it came from
Heaven that every language in NP has a
zero knowledge proof I guess I need to
see how to do it okay actually I need
both points are related to each other
but you have to use both of them anyway
there's a theorem that the four-way
functions exist and every then three
color ability has a zero knowledge proof
that's the theorem if there's one wave
function then three color ability has a
zero knowledge proof okay then from this
I can conclude that every language in NP
has a zero knowledge proof by equivalent
reduction both of these steps have
something that might seem non-blackbox
about that the first step is like you
know how do you prove that theorem that
one-way function implies zero knowledge
for three colorability how do you use
the one-way function to use it in a
black box way or not okay so today we
know how to use it in a black box way
the second part is I want to prove zero
knowledge not for three collaborability
but for my language and that requires a
action that reduction is not Black Box
because it uses the non-deterministic
turing machine but this is less
important as I said before the proof is
more important that was vinod's Point am
I right the proof is more important and
so and the proof is Black Box in any
case
so there's no good examples
uh right of non-black books so I guess
the answer to you is basically
everything is Black Box
um I mean that makes this black box
separation much more interesting but
right now like all these new
constructions are like are you sure
everything that uses
good good I know I forgot I had a
sentence about it even here
um yeah oracleated separations even
cryptography that's zero I think all
these are examples of constructions that
yeah but that's what you
but the most important part is the proof
really well how about cryptography and
mc0 that seems very non-black
boxes yeah but the proof is Black Box
you take an adversary exactly yeah I use
the atmosphere as a black box but IR
it's not known how to do that for only
black box uh Productions it really
relies on the construction people
platform so you're saying there could be
a construction of public encryption from
one-way functions where the construction
is uh
um uses carbon schemes yeah not black
box but the proof is still Black Box
yeah
that's a great open question like it's a
great open question in the sense that
it's likely to be solved very nice that
has a nice kind of like conditional not
Black Box uh Black Box separation but
reconstructions love to be you know
black box but it's conditional and it's
very partial and so it's it's very hard
what that means
so you really need to invent a new
non-blackbox construction data
could you repeat the question yeah so so
so so sorry so the point here is that
thank you by the way functions
uh which um where the proof the
reduction is black box but the
construction is not black box that seems
totally open that's the point uh but
there are
negative it's a very limited negative
very limited editions let's say well
maybe not
no let's see it
but God blessings
right right right just look at the gate
by gate by gate
where the proofs is not black box
yeah
interactive simulator is not black box
so yeah it doesn't fit in this airplane
no like direct doesn't directly but then
if you use Barack as a building block to
build something else like normal for
secure Coastal classical computation and
so on then you do want a reduction and
the reduction uses that simulator
in its Valley it's there for the
uh so there are non-black box uh
reductions that use is this internal
simulation technique
the reduction
you want to say any attacker that breaks
the scheme can be used to invert the one
if I go remember that picture that I had
like for like five years
so then you can use that factor is the
code of the attacker that's what the
direct insurance
I know the hour is up but let me stop at
a reasonable stopping point and we'll
still have half an hour off okay
um which will be very soon
um
so
okay this is
um about what the meaning of it I think
the my favorite one is the bottom Point
uh if you have a black box operation it
really gives you Insight if you want to
construct that's what I like the most
about Black Box operations if you want
to construct one from the other
um it gives you ideas of what not to try
and where yes to go
um
good so I wanted to say and I forgot who
asked this Valentina or somebody made a
comment about things being equivalent so
in fact all of this is highly
non-equivalent to each other and
all of all of these separations are
known and in fact it was hard to draw so
I didn't draw but even early on rudish
proved that key agreement in K rounds is
separated from Key agreement and K plus
one round for any K so they're in fact
infinite so what I just said about
rudish that already shows an infinite
hierarchy but these incomparability
results show there's not even it's
infinite and it's not a hierarchy even
they're incomparable World okay so
um
like there's infinitely many
incomparable uh worlds in crypto Mania
like these are all so remember I
promised you all the colors all of these
are possible worlds so it's like a big
mess
okay I think this is a good stopping
point
um
right it's beautiful you see what I
meant in the beginning
um good so let's take a break and then
I'll continue I have a little more to
say about these worlds I didn't say
anything about uh obfuscation but I also
wanted to talk about some open problems
uh later that are not from this era but
some newer ones
[Applause]
just in time
I can take questions now or later or
whatever you want
specialization which is
I won't get to know ask so what's the
question yeah so
everything that is all this discussion
with Rafael Raphael right now
I'm relatively
because is that true sorry it's the
opposite yes it's a black box implies
relativizing
yes no I see I don't know of any example
your question does makes what I said is
wrong but your question makes sense but
I don't know
no I think it's
yeah right Rafael do you know I think I
think that there's no example of
something that's
yes Black Box
based constructions right which ones
like like for example showing that you
can de-randomize now our commitments
with under with circuit lower balance
maybe you call this a non-relativizing
instruction I'm not sure I don't know
you're saying but it is black box but
not relative I would consider it Black
Box you use a prg to generate some
Randomness yeah and if you would
consider it I don't know the answer
that's interesting I thought there were
no examples like that but I actually
don't know oh I know that I don't know
the case here it's algebra
yeah it doesn't seem relevant yeah
Oracle
so their knowledge is
also not quite fun
that was the question if you know
something that's black box but not some
black book Supply devices so yeah so
maybe it was the opposite if it's black
box it's relative I think you were
asking something that's not black box
I'm just confused and yes because one
hand it sort of it seems like it's not
really in some sense but it's also Black
Box in some sense
exactly yeah good that's that's the
right answer the theorem is black box
and the one-way function you just use
one of your functions to build
commitments
but then when you use zero knowledge
that's when you when it's not right
because you look at the
circuit
it's good
we'll talk more later
[Applause]